voici le nouveau smartphone pliant de la
marque tekno c'est le Phantom vfold
alors on retrouve vraiment le form
factor du Samsung Galaxy Z fold 4 il est
un petit peu dur à ouvrir alors la
charnière là je trouve un petit peu trop
lâche mais sur le principe le format
reconnaît bien là on sent quasiment pas
la peure c'est très très très bien
réussi de ce côté-là bon le formator il
est connu il est reconnu la différence
qu'on va retrouver par rapport au
dernier smartphone de Samsung c'est
qu'on a bien la caméra ici n'a pas de
caméra planqué sur l'écran on retrouve
néanmoins un très grand écran extérieur
ici j'aime bien une fois de plus l'idée
d'avoir un côté un peu texturé le design
est assez sympa avec cette symétrie un
peu comme je te retrouve aujourd'hui
chez Honor avec le côté oeil de Muse
qu'on avait avant et puis des symétrique
là qui est légèrement décentré avec la
petite caméra sur le côté la gamme
Phantom aussi qui est assez jolie ici et
pour un rendu qui est pas mal un
smartphone qui tourne sur un processeur
de médiathèque par contre celui-là parce
que vous en pensez dites-moi comment
vous le trouvez est-ce que c'est un
format qui vous plaît ce format là
est-ce qu'il vous botte oui ou non tout
en sachant que vous ne trouverez pas de
toute façon sur le marché français ça va
être uniquement distribué on a des et en
as